we got the story from Fox News teen
takeover terrorizes Chicago as hundreds
of teenagers destroy property and attack
tourists so Saturday so I mean I mean
look I'd love to to go in on that joke
with you my friend but no no
I just this is nuts so I think that's
the means of hundreds to thousands of
teenagers romping through the city
jumping on cars setting vehicles on fire
smashing Windows just today it was
reported they tried breaking into the
Art Institute it's only April too and
it's only April I mean Summer's gonna
get gonna get wild yeah and it's
happening in L.A but so I don't know in
the Art Institute I have to imagine has
probably got billions of dollars worth
of Art in there and if they got in it
would have been like history being
ransacked apparently I don't know how it
went down but they're trying to break in
and two two of the teens got shot
gunshots ring out everyone's scatters
there's no reason this is not a protest
they're not pissed off about anything
this is just societal and cultural brain
takedown of people rampaging through the
cities there's these videos I can't even
play these videos for you on YouTube
that's how crazy it is there's a there's
videos there's a woman standing in a
doorway at a building doing nothing they
run up grab her and just start
mercilessly beating her for no reason yo
it's getting crazy by the head and you
could see people like you could see
people just hooking no reason right no
yeah new mayor in charge yet I don't
think he's in charge not in charge yet
right but I'm pretty sure he did come
out and he said it's not constructive to
vilify the group of Rowdy teams that
torched cars in Rampage organized on
social media you know what though you
know what though
I mean it's horrifying to see what's
happening in it's it's happening in La
too it's probably coming to a city near
you but uh I gotta be honest I mean I'm
happy for the people of Chicago
I'm I'm very happy I mean that woman I
don't know her personally but there's a
very strong possibility she voted for
this you
look so so I'll put it this way like no
nobody should be attacked it shouldn't
happen and this lady is an individual I
don't blame her for any of this but as a
body of citizens Chicago has been under
Democrat control for over a hundred
years and this all of this stuff so you
made the joke another Saturday yeah
because of the perception of what
Chicago is having grown up there I've
certainly seen similar things to this
but never this bad and at this point now
I'm like I'm not surprised this is the
traject the trajectory of the city you
keep voting for this stuff over and over
again don't be surprised the new
mayor-elect says don't demonize them
it's not constructive
I don't understand how anybody could be
shocked that this is happening in
Chicago I mean there's already a culture
that looting and writing has no
consequences there hasn't been
accountability in that City in a very
long time you can even see what the
mayor-elect is saying doesn't take
accountability and the other part of his
statement I read that he was saying
something along the lines of how you
can't blame these kids because this is a
city that doesn't have enough
opportunities for them it is the left's
fault that there's not opportunity there
because why would any company want to be
located in Chicago where they're going
to have their buildings burned down
they're going to be robbed there's going
to be shootings every day they're losing
money but then you're upset when they
leave Chicago even though you've done
nothing to protect them you're always
demonizing them you're always saying
that they need to pay more in taxes you
have not made the city of Chicago a
place that any business would want to be
or a place that any business could
survive and now you're shocked that the
kids there quote unquote don't have
enough opportunity on purpose and this
was happening during uh 2020 riots in
Minnesota right businesses would get
looted and shut down or bricks through
the window and then stores that people
need to go to to be able to get supplies
things that actually matter you know
whether it's groceries things like that
you know baby formula and then nobody
can get to them for days at a time while
they're either repairing what's going on
there or they're just simply waiting out
the riots to end and nobody it doesn't
ever click in their brain that in a lot
of ways when you live in the city I
wasn't even living in Minneapolis this
time I was in the outskirts I was in
West Saint Paul and this stuff was still
happening and you understand that this
is going to keep happening unless you
learn to vote in people who are willing
to put into place different policies or
at the very least keep them in jail and
not just let them out on bail right away
that's what they're doing and if you
look back at the old videos of the
Looting and rioting that happens look
very closely at those videos you will be
hard-pressed to find someone stealing
eggs or a pack of chicken or something
that they need to put food on the table
or even blankets for their kids to stay
warm no they're selling TVs they're
selling air pods they're understanding
all these things that they don't need
and saying it's in the name of
reparations but they're not doing this
for anything productive it's just
complete selfishness with no
accountability remember when AOC said
they're looting because they need bread
yeah yeah and everyone's like have you
seen a video of them looting dude
they're stealing shoes now you can argue
they need shoes yeah but like they're
still good shoes and the counters are
still full of bread nobody even took it
did you see that's the bread did you see
the video of the lady trying who asked
for the thousand dollars and said this
is my Rosa Parks moment at the Target
what okay
um did you see this no okay so this lady
basically says like she wants to get her
stuff for free and starts like harassing
the lady who works at the Target or
whatever and the security guard she
starts yelling The Secret Garden backs
the security guard up into his office
and the dude just knocks her out wow and
then she got arrested because she got in
everyone's face and got and got physical
this is where we're going man she called
it her Rosa Parks moment into the
groceries for reparations for I I feel
like all of these policies put forth by
democrats are actually intended to harm
Democrats and then you get these
Democrat voters being like for some
reason Republicans keep voting against
their own interests and it's like dude
the the social welfare policies are
actually ruining the economic standards
ruining families making things worse
they want you to sterilize and abort
your kids I don't think they like you
very much I think their policies are
intent on making your life worse and you
look at what's going on in Chicago and
when this guy said when this mayor like
says don't do this Brandon Johnson don't
demonize these teenage boys too 16 17
were shot and he's like well you know
they it's almost like they want this
stuff to happen bad things to all the
people of the city but you know what man
I can't be mad about it because they
voted for it so it's like if you're a
conservative or a moderate and you live
in Chicago
I guess at this point I'm like I'm sorry
that this is happening to you I guess
but like you're choosing to live in a
city where all of this stuff is going
down and I know people always say oh but
it's like you don't understand I don't
have the money I can't move it's too
hard
the example that I give is
if your house was on fire you wouldn't
stop and think well I could leave but I
have nowhere else to go no you run out
the door you stand barefoot outside
thinking what do I do now so these
people were saying like I can't get out
of Chicago all you're really telling me
is the fire hasn't reached your house
yet
you can't convince me that the left is
not a death cult because everything that
they stand for both legislatively and
ideologically just relate to the demise
of society whether it's obesity whether
it's how hard they push for abortion
whether it's allowing all these crimes
and murders to happen in the cities
everything that you look at with them
leads to depopulation or it leads to
just less people happening even
everything with same sex is like they
don't even want these heterosexual
couples to be able to have kids they're
wanting to sterilize kids with the Trans
stuff everything that the left does
leads to death has anybody else noticed
that yeah and that's why I was saying
like I don't think they like you very
much like you go to your politician and
the the Republican guy says hey man you
should have more kids it's like okay
he's basically telling you to survive he
likes you there should be more of you
these Democrats go you have you
considered aborting that baby and it's
like that's something you would say to
someone you don't like like you go to
you if there's a like these two women
right imagine there's two men and one
one woman is pregnant and they hate each
other's guts yeah one woman the the one
woman's gonna go and be like abort your
kid like that's not a nice thing to say
to somebody they'll probably call
themselves humanists as well yes they'll
say they'll say we are secular humanists
and they'll tell you that they believe
that they want good things for the human
race but they want fewer humans it's not
that they dislike you it's that they
like the planet more therefore they want
the planet to survive because humans
according to them are basically a blight
it is dude look at this look at this
video look at this video this is this is
Compton California gas station and these
Street takeovers have been happening all
over the city where people are just
smashing their way in
just that's it welcome to life in uh Los
Angeles and this is similar to Chicago
the crazy thing is there's like this
video of one dude just like smacking a
bunch of condoms off a shelf into the
air and it's like he's not looting dude
it's it's not even ransacking it's just
it's Rampage and all and it all it takes
is one person that decides they want to
be violent like they could be all
looters except for one dude that's just
like all right I'm gonna go in there and
I'm gonna break the guy you know the
person working behind the the counter's
face open and those type of agitators
end up at those types of absolutely
absolutely because they get the
opportunity it's like people talk about
um people talk about you know the church
when priests that are molesting kids or
whether it's schools and stuff the thing
is they go where the access is Predators
go over the accesses so predators are
gonna go to where people are rioting so
that way if they want to be violent for
no reason they're going to go to where
the riots are this is the story from
Ferguson when I was on the ground and uh
the the hardcore fans of Tim cast have
heard me tell the story a billion times
so bear with us for those that didn't
hear it uh simple version is a bunch of
young black men linked arms to protect
the liquor store that Michael Brown had
stolen the cigarillos from and when they
were interviewed by a guy from Al
Jazeera he's like why are you protecting
the store they said the people who are
looting and burning down these stores
don't live here our community is being
destroyed right now
I remember watching across the street a
bunch of people ran and smashed Windows
started stealing stuff from a bunch of
stores and the locals who lived there
were begging for help to stop the
rioting
but people from other other
neighborhoods said now's our chance and
came in and started stealing and
destroying things and then leftists
wrote a wrote an article Alexis wrote an
article saying in defense of looting and
all of these white liberals come out and
said the reason that they're rioting and
looting in their own neighborhood is
because they're resisting the
bourgeoisie and the elites and I'm like
bro I was there the people who lived
there were begging for help to stop the
Looting of their neighborhood like
nobody wants their gas station burned
down nobody wants their local food court
burned down it's the people who don't
live there who are stealing everything
they can and then fleeing and the left
was coming in and cheering for it and
people that don't live there making
excuses for the people that are coming
into town stealing I gotta say I really
do think that a lot of these liberal
leftist types are actually overtly white
supremacist and just pretending not to
be because think about what they've done
remember that video where the two white
women are vandalizing property in a
black neighborhood and the two black
girls are like stop destroying our
neighborhood and like don't worry we're
doing it for you like come on if take
the context out of this and say just go
go up to any leftist any even when
you're liberal friends not leftists but
like a liberal friend say if you saw two
white people destroying a black neighbor
what would you think
because I'll tell you what a
conservative would think I'm like oh
antifa again huh because we get it
because people on the right people
libertarian I don't mean to imply I'm
concerned I'm saying people who are
post-liberal who are libertarian Freedom
facts you like to call it have been
paying attention to the news and see
this incessant white liberal rampaging
in black neighborhoods that happened
especially in 2020 and then they come
out and they say we're here to support
you and then they burn down your your
grocery store yeah sorry I don't I don't
I don't believe you I think you might
just be a white supremacist in the
classical sense say destroy your
neighborhood and they run off businesses
but they're here to help guys when they
write a book called in defense of
looting I think I think it's a book now
yeah it is I'm like I gotta think that
you're actually just a white supremacist
who wants to go and ruin you know they
talk about uh the bombing of Black Wall
Street are you familiar with this was it
Tulsa I think it was I believe so and
and
what what am I supposed to think about
what they're doing when you see two
white women destroying black businesses
and they say don't worry doing it for
you I'm kind of like I don't know it
feels a whole lot like that you know
what Democrats have always done you know
I just don't believe you and here we are
today this is what they do they claim
they fight for you but they actively
harm you not that Republicans are doing
a whole lot for Republicans mind you but
still one of the weirdest things back
when I was in the BLM culture and at
some of these protests I would say and
to be clear I never looted and I never
write it I always thought that was
insane but I would try to point out some
of the things that were really weird to
me like when I would watch the Looting
happening I would watch it on Twitch and
I would see why I'm assuming antifa
members breaking into these buildings in
these predominantly black neighborhoods
and I would ask myself I'm like why are
white people going in and destroying
these black owned businesses and then
saying that it's for racial Justice I
didn't understand it but when I would
bring those type of things up at the
rallies out people will turn to me and
be like Oh either you're all in or
you're all out like I would just be shut
down like it was not a conversation when
I would bring up like there's so many
white people here it's like how many of
them are stealing and saying it's in the
name of reparations it was the weirdest
thing to me that nobody was willing to
actually point out all the black
communities being destroyed yeah
is part of that just because they feel
like they need to organize and they need
to do something therefore if they're not
allowed to criticize it they just have
to accept it for them well I think part
I think that's definitely a big part of
it and I think part of it was they knew
that their what they were fighting for
wasn't as concrete as they wanted it to
be so the second you start poking any
holes into BLM and that entire narrative
that the woke left had and still has
things start to crumple apart so they
don't want any holes poked in it at all
it's you have to believe in every single
thing that they say or you're kicked out
of the cold
and they shut you down if you do try to
speak about it anyways absolutely yeah I
mean you see that um
currently there's a kerfuffle on the
left about uh Anna kasparian she made
some remarks about her disliking uh
birthing people she doesn't want to be
called a birthing person yeah I think
that was the first or a person with a
womb shocking I caught a stream
uh Stitch and Adam were doing a stream
talk they were covering a bunch of left
left-leaning people uh some people from
the Surfs and Matt Bender was on there
and they were they were just tearing her
down like just saying she's not allowed
to say this like really making it clear
that it was unacceptable that she had
stepped out of line and hadn't had
expressed a dissenting opinion it just
absolutely a guess and they went on and
on and apparently there was two
different streams where these five or
six people were going at her so I it's
not a surprise to hear that at all
um you know and it's something that I
think that the left has a significant
problem with the fact that you can't
have a descending opinion we're gonna
have one of those guys uh on the show I
think not this week maybe maybe in a
week or two a big big Lefty Twitter
personality interesting one of the
reasons that is too is because the media
tends to Parrot their beliefs right back
at them because they believe the same
thing that the media believes so they're
never challenged on a daily basis if if
you are center right or libertarian your
views are constantly challenged by the
media you take in you know if you're
taking in any type of mainstream media
you're having your Viewpoint challenge
you might think they're wrong and most
of the time they are but you're at least
being given opposing viewpoints on a
regular basis and if you don't if you're
not used to hearing that that's a lot of
times shocking and that's where the
emotional responses tend to come in
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time